we strongly condemn all acts of violence
and we do believe that the recent
operations of the security forces have
been disproportionate
and we're worried about the resulting
alarming number of people who've been
killed
we also condemn acts of terrorism such
as the murder of policemen in Sinai
we've seen attacks on government
installation
destruction of churches very worried
about the Coptic churches and mosques we
call on all sides to stop this cycle of
violence to stop the provocations to
stop the hate speech
we want and urge all political parties
to engage in a real and inclusive
dialogue to restore the Democratic
process a national dialogue that can be
opened to all
political groups shouldn't be excluded
as long as they renounce violence and
they respect Democratic principles
political reconciliation and working
together is surely the right solution
the European Union and me personally We
Stand ready to support Egypt in this
process
we've agreed as well to review the issue
of our assistance to Egypt with the
understanding that assistance to the
most vulnerable groups and to Civil
Society must continue
member states have agreed to suspend
export licenses to Egypt of any
equipment used for internal repression
and to reassess their export licenses
covered by the EU common position this
of course is member State competence